fox news has some new polling out about
what's going on with biden and hispanics
it's super interesting president biden's
approval rating among hispanic americans
has plummeted to 26 percent according to
a wednesday poll from quinnipiac
university biden is less popular among
hispanics than any other demographic
including age and gender the poll found
the same quinnipiac poll conducted last
year put hispanic support at biden at 55
percent biden has been consistently
hitting new low new lows in the poll for
nearly a year
young americans and white men
also have low approvals for biden at 27
and 29 respectively the president's
highest approval ratings are among
americans older than 65
and black americans at 45 and 63
respectively black americans are the
only demographic in which biden has a
positive approval rating according to
the poll so first off let me talk about
that part
the 63 black approval rating for joe
biden to me is just because they have
confused people because of the lunatics
at msnbc and the crazy joy reads and the
endless screaming that somehow
republicans are racist if the democrat
policies of big government and handouts
and welfare and all of these things
worked then
why are people still in welfare why do
we have this generational stuff right
read a thomas soul book you'll get it um
but they are losing and they are losing
terribly and they're fueling it
themselves because they always double
down
when is the last time you saw a liberal
or a democrat say boy maybe we're doing
some of this wrong maybe we should
rethink some of this stuff maybe not all
of our opponents are crazy racists maybe
some of our big government policies
maybe punishing people for success by
taking more of their money just so we
can put it into government programs that
don't really do anything maybe some of
this doesn't work and we should look in
the mirror for a second and come up with
better policies well they never do that
they always double down and this video
i'm about to show you this is from the
televised mental institution of msnbc uh
this is a guy by the name of donnie
douche and donny douche great name like
this is the most on point name ever
donny douche over here uh he's a
branding expert and he is accepting on
msnbc that the democrats are getting
slaughtered so what does he say they
have to do oh it's just extraordinary
enjoy what is the best way to push back
on this hatred what's the best way to
push back on this conspiracy theory
that that's based on a jewish
international banker uh i mean just it
is so anti-semitic uh and of course
they've they've slaughtered george soros
in there trying to make the country like
browner and black or what's the best way
for people to push back on that lie you
you take this heinous platform and you
make the republicans own it i want to
say it again make the republicans own it
every republican politician every
republican candidate ask them about it
make them because they can they can't
run from it because it's it's part of
who they are at this point it's
disgusting as that is but make it the
republican
replacement theory mainstream it because
if this is the way you have to scare we
don't have the economy on our side as
democrats so you have to scare the
bejesus out of people the way to scare
that is say you know this replacement
theory this is not just coming from some
dark corner of the web this is the
republican platform make them own the
democrats run from this fist fight i
know in the previous segment eugene
daniels he talked about the president
not wanting to call out names call out
tucker carlson call the politicians and
make this make them own it this is a
republican platform it's the racist
republican replacement theory do you see
what donny douche just said on the
television mental institution of msnbc
he said and this the clip goes on and on
i didn't want to belabor with you
because it's early in the day you're
trying to live a good life so i can't
have you watching too many of those
clips and i'm about to show you
something from the view so i'm just
trying to be respectful for you
um he's basically saying oh this
replacement theory we should run with
this this idea that you know that
republicans are all
they're afraid that white people are
going to be replaced blah blah blah he's
saying we can't win on the economy we
can't win on any of the real things so
we just have to label them racist he's
not saying that they're racist this is a
branding expert who was brought on to
explain what the democrats should do
it's very rare that they actually tell
you how calculatingly evil they are but
that's what donnie douche said right
there donnie douche he should have been
in the sopranos